how's everybody doing hello good thank
you how are you
good good so who who wants to let me in
on what the group
chat was like between all of you when
this kept getting delayed
a lot of emojis that uh had an angry
many emojis
who was the who was the most vocal like
who out of all of you were the one that
just could not believe
that this kept happening
josh
now that it is now that you guys are
ready to sort of you know
share it with the share it with the rest
of the world
um what are your what are your feelings
how are you feeling about it now
uh it's nice you know you take a break
away from something i mean obviously it
would have been great
it came out when it came out but having
had that distance and then
getting to go see it it felt really
really fresh
you know when we got to watch it uh so
yeah i'm just excited finally that
people get to see
this you know this what we made i'm
really proud of it i think it's uh
you know it's really just as to what the
story always wanted to be
so it's just as exciting really
and uh henry i'll start with you here um
so much is faith-based when you do a
movie like this where
what you see on screen is not what you
guys saw on set
that day how did the your expectations
in your head uh how did they that live
up to when you finally saw this and saw
what they had done
i was incredibly frustrated they didn't
light me on fire
um it was
it was awesome it was you have to use so
much of your imagination to
uh not only see yourself um you know nut
up
uh as well as the other members of the
cast create these
uh force fields or make dragons come to
life and
it's an exercise for for
for it's a challenge for you as an actor
and as a person to to dive into these
worlds and it was exciting
you know to to do it together you just
remember
yeah go ahead i was just saying you just
remember when we got to see it in march
i remember
first couple of minutes i remember being
like i'm so tall
oh yeah he gave me huge to make me six
foot because in the comics is really
tall
right what was it like being six foot
for a little while
it's cool it was cool you know nick
holder
he was cool and uh anya i'll ask you
this um
this world that you guys are are in when
it comes to the
fan base we know that they waited they
waited patiently they made art while
they waited
they made blogs while they waited they
wrote stories while they waited
um what is your sort of like take on
just the fan base that
is already in place that cannot wait to
see this
it's the most wonderful feeling to be a
fan like
i love being a fan of so many different
things and i understand that
vehement love um so it's really
wonderful to have seen everybody's
creative outbursts because it's nice to
see that that's what they're doing with
the time rather than just like
ranting so that's you know a healthy way
of processing it
um but you know i think you just feel
incredibly humbled and honored to be a
part of something that people love so
much and
whenever i've really really loved
something like a book and then it's
become a movie
i always hope that they don't try and
make it what the book was but they make
it
something that supplements it so you
don't feel like they're trying to
replace it in any way and i hope that
new mutants supplements the comics
for the people that love them and
quickly before i go charlie are you guys
back in production on stranger things or
when is that happening
not yet no uh no we're still on hiatus
you know because of uh kovid so we're
not sure i mean we're hoping to go back
as soon as we can
but obviously it has to be safe for that
to happen so
whenever it's safe i'm sure we'll find
out and get
amazing yeah all right mutants thank you
so much
i appreciate your time